we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
ah
here we are
we might be drunk we're back we're off
the road we're in manhattan it's holiday
season
what are we drinking today
uh we got some gin and tonics
all right the beard transitioned fully
not really a cold weather drink but what
the hell what the hell nice in here you
know what these thank you internal
affairs it's great
what what's great about these is you
have them
while you're waiting for the family you
know when the food's cooking you throw a
few of these in yeah and you can handle
your aunt i love a gin and tonic oh yeah
i prefer like the soda i don't know the
sugar just you don't think of tonic as
having sugar i know but it's got sugar i
just don't like the sugar is just
you just feel gross yeah
the poison i can do it's the sugar
you don't taste it either isn't that
weird when there's sugar in something
and you don't taste sugary yeah so it's
a waste of waste yeah what i'm getting
the calories and none of the sweet yeah
it's like when you find out you're like
fake news you're like they're not even
that healthy i know remember
snackwells pull up snackwells oh you got
the malamar's
malamar don't get me started on uh
devil's food [ __ ] all that [ __ ] um
was it snackwells malamar's here's my
issue with malamar's there's too much
going on piccolaine you got you got the
you got the marshmallow the graham
cracker crust and the is that graham
cracker what is it that that's a cookie
cookie crust cookie crust cookie crust
they're good it's not my go-to i'm a
simple man i didn't realize until just
this moment but that's a s'more
no s'more is a comedian
she's a black lady community remember
geraldo's gross joke andre goes when it
comes to comedy shows we could use some
less
[Laughter]
once
did you she was great yeah she's yeah
she seems cool super cool i mean she's
been through the ringer yeah all those
older black comics are like seasoned
yeah and you know much like those black
shows when you're coming up or like
sorry i go by old bay
[Laughter]
uh no those black shirts i remember like
mike lawrence and i used to go to like
moga's lounge oh yeah
i went to a few of those with uh smokey
smoky yeah he was cool super cool super
funny and like you see these guys up in
these harlem rooms and you're like you
guys are all amazing but you'll never
make it you know you're all like 64.
you're smoking on stage you're killing
me you got a cane you got diabetes
you're calling the lady in the front row
a hoe
murdering and they're all brilliant and
hilarious but they're just stuck in
harlem
sad
it's a fun room though um and i remember
watching lawrence just do like uh comic
book references that they're just like
what
we don't [ __ ] watch this [ __ ]
that motherfucker's an aquaman
but then you know i i had i remember i
had one i i remember i had one joke
killing there that was just like phil i
mean you it gave you confidence you're
like it's a different type of crap oh
you know it's coliseum it's either this
or this yeah you know there's not much
in the middle either crushed or they
booed you they smell fear you're dead oh
yeah and you got to try not to do the
token white guy because that's that's
what your brains like just get out just
do the token white guy it's easy
they'll love it but you gotta be you
yeah first time i went full token really
yeah i was scared and they played some
like two chains to bring me up and i was
like two chains why not one and they're
like
oh
you know
just uh
i had to play ball you know
corny's like the highest praise from a
black crowd no what's not bad no
highest play praise is
you crazy or you're stupid stupid stupid
all insults yeah i know
[Laughter]
stupid it's like you're [ __ ]
little dick like all right cut it out
we love you no no you are stupid that's
stupid while they're laughing is good oh
he's stupid yeah yeah that's good or uh
yeah what else is good uh crazy's good
crazy's good yeah
he don't play
i don't know that was the martin
lawrence special you so crazy that's
right that's right yeah yeah richard
pryor special
oh and that word's crazy yeah yeah
that's tough uh asking for the record i
know
i know i don't want to uh i have some
records at home that i want to put up
and i'm like i can't put a bicentennial
n-word on my wall oh i got that that's
on my wall really yeah right next to
cosby and then woody allen
i got an epstein record up there
he did a christmas album
i forgot julian's greatest hits my
favorite the 12 kids of christmas
all right
um
yeah man the i i don't i mean we can try
them i'm not i've never had one i
maybe i'll be wrong i haven't had them
forever because i'm a simple man i like
like a lorna dune i want a shortbread
cookie with my coffee or a dune what's
that it sounds like a writer shortbread
cookie yeah
who's lorna dune
have you read lauren dunes review on the
uh symphony
it sounds like a like a women's uh
mystery writer yeah yeah the lorna dune
what is a lorna dune it's that little
thing
oh yeah those are good cookies man i
don't just that box looks like my
grandma's house i i wouldn't walk right
through your grandma's
no that's a lot dustier
but uh
oh hey thank you wow these are beautiful
yeah
i thought it looks like a uh
macaroon
yes which sounds like a racial slur by
the way
you have a macaron remember your old bit
about uh how every chinese restaurant
the names just sound like a slur yes you
goddamn golden noodles
uh let's see panda king panda king was
the big one yeah that that was like my
big first big bit in new york
it is good oh
i was wrong let's show the candy shell
i'll give it a big man
okay a big man really seems too good
everybody drink
pretty good great
it's just it's just very rich like first
few bites are good but like how many of
these can you i guess that's good
they're only available like november to
january you can't get them like the
mcrib of candy is that is that true yeah
yeah they shut it down i don't know why
they shut it down i don't know it's like
too rich
maybe it's a marketing thing they know
you'll buy it more if it's special yeah
like a breakfast
yeah what they got me yeah they got you
these are great you know what's great
about it there's a lot going on
but they make it work
they got they keep it in line
now the secret is to freeze them oh
boy
yeah that's a real treat all right yeah
that sounds good yeah like freezing
candy like charleston chew frozen pretty
good i think i brought that up before
but i don't like hard foods so i'm not
in the freezing
yeah you don't freeze ever no i don't
freeze
no freeze i'm
hey anti-freeze about the fridge will
you do the fridge i'll do fridge but
freezer just makes things hard i can't
have a crouton i can't have a biscoff
yeah and it's candies to me that's a
perfect candy i'm not gonna ruin it with
making it hard
yeah i wonder i wonder if the people who
are in charge i'm sure they don't care
but maybe there's like some you know
malamar purists out there who are like
you don't freeze it right that's not how
you consume the malamar yes now there is
a bar called frozen you ever had one of
those no no it's called a zero oh we
brought this up sorry sorry zero is
meant to be frozen because like zero
degrees oh how about those uh ice cream
candy bars like you get like a twix or
snickers ice cream bar
or choco taco
those are so good that you feel guilty
eating them
you know yeah i've never i've never
gotten one of those not high i don't
think yeah
like that is like a high person's that's
what you crave mm-hmm that's the twix
the twix ice cream
bars i don't know snickers is hard to
beat but
oh [ __ ] i had a point damn it
oh tom paul f tompkins used to have this
great bit he's like what's better cake
or pie and everybody's yelling cake pie
pie goes
cake is better because it has frosting
and when you eat frosting you feel shame
that's how good it is it was it was a
great bit i remember that bit it was
like a long bed long bit he could really
milk yeah he was good gross so good his
first album impersonal give that a whirl
yeah
milk like a prostitute as well
what uh
yeah malamar's these are pretty good man
i gotta give it to you and i feel like i
wouldn't have like ten of these which is
nice like i have oreos i mean the whole
box oh yeah oreos are [ __ ] good and
now they have too many flavors or
they're getting carried away i do like
that double stuff though double stuff is
is i mean that's you know what we like
you gave it to us yes exactly i like the
blonde one though too i like the the
blonde yeah i like the maybe it's not
called the blonde maybe which is called
the the honky i don't know what it's
called i prefer the interracial the
original black and white
it's pretty good but dude i like the uh
and something about an oreo that's
pretty classic yeah i agree
now let me ask you this tomorrow is
hanukkah or the first day it is it's
hanukkah it's day six oh we're already
on day six yeah wow it flew by
uh
do you do stuff do you get a gift every
day do you give a gift what are we doing
i don't know
everything's gotten weird you know it's
like how many things are we gonna do i
mean it's a lot of things i want to get
my my folks something but yeah i mean
i don't my my i remember i tell you a
bit about like how my family was cheap
you know they'd be like you know night
one you get a bike handle bars
[Laughter]
you know yeah and then builds to a bike
goes to a bike but like yeah i mean it
was like
everyone says like hanukkah is better
because not everyone there's a few jews
i don't think everyone's saying hanukkah
is better that came out wrong a few
proud boys disagree have you proud boys
like actually hanukkah is pretty cool
that god is there no you get you get
eight crazy nights so that's the whole
thing but then it's like the truth is
you they kind of
it's usually one cool thing and a bunch
of like guys like on night one hanukkah
chocolates
guilt
and you're just like all right
socks [ __ ] that you love as an adult but
as a kid you're just like i mean as an
adult socks are you guys one of those
socks i got you right yeah as an adult
it's fine but as a kid as a kid it's
brutal it's like vegetables you
appreciate it as an adult well said the
sock is the vegetable of gifts yeah you
don't get it till later yeah that's good
yeah i don't know terry schiavo is the
vegetable of people oh man
yes
whatever happened to her i don't think
it ended well ah did they pull the plug
yeah oh good well you know she went
peacefully i don't know i think that
looks rough was there i think there's
like a nine-year fight between her
parents and her husband uh the husband
said pull the plug parent said no oh wow
it's also a great yeah it's a great
symbol for this country can't agree on
anything
right now that was kyle ridden house of
its day that's what it was
and then what's up with kevorkian
remember that guy oh dr death doctor
death that guy was the king
i mean is it wrong what do you think i
mean i went to him with strep and he
said i should kill myself but
i thought that was rough ah you're like
i got a zit and he's like do it and
we put the gun down doctor jesus
yeah i mean he people wanted to die and
he helped him i don't know some could
say he's a hero
yeah pacino played him in a movie oh
yeah i'm killing people oh yeah
she was a [ __ ]
you broke my heart
i knew it was you
uh
so sam is a new york jew how do you
spell hanukkah what's the proper i go i
go with the h the classic but okay
people do the ch
who does that israelis do ch american
jews do h i don't even know the
difference i don't know the difference
either but i will tell you i i go h
why are we confusing people here
yeah i don't know
i don't know i only celebrate juneteenth
so
mark's a kwanzaa man yes the celebration
of lights
no idea what kwanzaa is hanukkah's f i
mean sandler made me feel like cool to
be a jew as a kid there weren't like a
lot of those but the hanukkah song
you're like all right
sandler really kind of helped you really
did he put it on the map woody allen i
like as a kid i liked but he wasn't cool
sandler was like a cool jew yes he was
he was cute and funny and he listed
that's how far off jews were he had to
list jews to be like look you like us
you know he had to be like paul newman's
half yeah that's a great song yeah paul
newman's have jewish goldy haunts have
to put them together what a fine
jew
that was classic dude yeah he's like oh
sorry no
as a non-jew in louisiana i heard that
song and i was like this is great and it
was informative i didn't know about any
of that [ __ ]
yeah it was great i mean look we got
some you know mari stodmart from the new
york knicks uh he converted
we got some cool people all right that
helped the old jewish team a lot
otherwise we're looking at guys from
like the 1950s like dolph shays
before black people played and we're
like yeah that's most of the jewish
although the israeli team is good now i
mean okay omari caspy there's some good
jews you got kofax
oh yeah
kofax was the man and edelman on uh
julian edelman yeah i don't know if he's
is he jewish i assume with that name he
might not be though he can't be real as
big oh that's hilarious yeah dude he's
going all in with the hat he's like a
pilgrim look at that yeah i love it
love damari he seemed like a good guy
now what's his what's his i mean i know
sammy davis went jewish i think for
marriage i think for marriage yeah
and then i don't know what do you think
he's doing it for i think he had just
really um
blood yeah hmm
all right how about that sam can you can
he play on saturday can you check what's
on the table here and vet this like is
this all like legit
i mean what is that grape juice oh it
looks like a little princess
samantha chef
yeah i'm not a great jew i'll be honest
it's more of my cultural aspects but
yeah i mean mata i like passover i like
the story of passover i like uh hanukkah
i mean i do the classics i'm not i'm not
i'm not rocking in there for sukkot you
know
i'm there for like you know the
high holidays yeah i i i just am jealous
as a big fat atheist nihilist you know
nothing matters guy it's gotta be nice
to have something
in your past your background you know
ethnicity in a way
i mean
i don't know yeah it's it's
i mean it's probably not that different
than what you're living though honestly
yeah that's true i mean true it's a
pastor i like those holidays like
passover because it's like oh you just
come you see family it's like almost
like you know
the way you see family on thanksgiving
it's nice yeah it's stressful but when
weinstein gets popped or made off or
epstein your mom's like oh a jew
we don't have that in my house we're
just like
whitey is very uh we're loners we don't
i don't care about other whitey i'm not
like yes rittenhouse got off you know
he's white there were there were there
are those guys
oh yeah good point but i mean uh yeah
that we were a smaller portion of the
population
so it's a little more personal i think
you know
there's a part of me when i see like
facebook all the high ups at facebook
like zuckerberg sandberg i'm like can we
get a [ __ ] o'malley in there
can we mix up the blame please right
right but you know you guys uh you
handle [ __ ] you run you run the office
[Laughter]
like a black guy will run the court well
i think kyle rittenhouse handled [ __ ] in
one way oh yeah good point good point
yeah he got [ __ ] done
that was his defense
he got [ __ ] done
yeah was his lawyer jewish
i don't know actually i mean the odds
would
say yes give it a go there's a ridden
house rye
oh really yeah ridden house the liquor
i'm sure i wonder if they're just like
did it have to be ridden house
right it's like our friend joe zimmerman
he's like come on you're killing me here
you think orange juice when oj did it
was like god damn it
well corona beer corona yeah there's a
million of them oh delta delta yeah i'm
sure they're furious
uh mark richards
all right probably a boy
yeah related to michael though who
dropped the n1 oh my god
we're rolling what is this you got up
here this this photo is beautiful is
that a midnight cowboy no it's close
it's dennis hopper
what movie american friend they're
playing
movie at the metrograph which one i
forgot the name of it the last the last
movie no from the early 80s it was with
oh this is american friend
maybe
dennis hopper was a cool dude oh very
cool dude yeah
yeah very cool he's an amazing
photographer as well if you ever look up
the amazing photographer if if you're
listening to this and you've never seen
like the classics like easy rider it's
kind of nicholson's breakout role too
i mean easy riders incredible yeah
that's a fun movie e five easy pieces is
in there for
yeah yeah but this was before that this
was his yeah that was i think what about
um
i'll tell you can i give you my wreck
because you kind of gave me a good shout
out for it
shout out to my buddy alex brazile
uh i know elle also great
dude he texts me and he he just texts me
noir stuff all the time he's in the noir
so he'll be like if you've seen detour
i'm like yeah have you seen out of the
past i'm like i have a big i got up out
of the past uh poster framed above my
desk i love it i love that movie robert
mitchum anyways like you got to get the
criterion collection here's my law he
gave me his login which i'm like i'm
going to have to just buy it to support
it because it's so cool dude the
criterion collection the the categories
are like
uh old new york
fox noir
uh you know like vehicles with robert
mitchum like these are all the
categories i'm like this [ __ ] rules
wow so i saw colin quinn do something
it's did you see it for criteria yes
yeah i didn't know he does his picks
like his best his top ten and they put
him just in a room of all the criteria
movements and he's pulling them off the
shelves
which is better than he recommended a
couple after so i watched like paul dano
and uh michael sarah in there too
and they were both great they're both i
saw safety brothers did it as well
yeah
it's cool on youtube yeah yeah oh okay
they're really fun yeah well i didn't
know like any of the movies quinn was
referencing so i felt dumb and i started
a lot of them are obviously on there
because that's the criterion so i'm like
i gotta i gotta watch this i love it so
that's my wreck and and they've got one
of my favorite movies on there so this
comes with another wreck uh it's an auto
preminger uh film noir from the 40s
starring dana andrews uh clifton webb
and gene tierney called laura it's
incredible
it's one of my favorite movies of all
time i've seen it probably five times i
own it on dvd wow but they have our
criteria i've never heard of it either
it's excellent and gene tierney was a
smoke show femme fatale
does she try to kill them i can't i
don't want to give the blood away 44.
dana andrews was a very good actor very
underrated uh
not like not more like a modern actor
okay
but very kind of understated for the for
that time but he was g and clifton webb
rules it's it's just a
cool ass movie i love it all right what
great name clifton webb oh he ruled he
was great
all right i'm down so that's my wreck
well give me a give me a wreck well
i was gonna say something similar to
this actually but my mom got me that
masterclass [ __ ] whoa it's pretty
good who are you watching i watched the
steve martin one and then there's a
scorsese one there's all these great
directors and and comedians and stuff
and writers uh what's his face paul
thomas anderson daniel d lewis i mean
the list goes on they got good people
and it's really good
paul thomas anderson is a new movie out
yeah
that looks more like kind of not like
his type of movie right it looks a
little softer like a little more
personal coming of age uh high school
teen movie philip seymour hoffman what
his son is that right yeah
i think
how do you feel about this because it's
like gandolfini's son philip seymour
you're four yeah but it's kind of a
weird form of nepotism like i know
hollywood runs on nepotism but to me it
is a little
uh
i saw tim dillon i thought make a great
point about this where he said
uh it's nothing new though i mean jamie
lee curtis is daughter of tony curtis
and gwyneth paltrow's dad was oh and
janet lee was her mother yeah there you
go yeah uh debbie reynolds and burt
reynolds sure
yeah elizabenelli yeah well also uh
nicholas cage is coppola's nephew right
yeah
jason schwartzman i think is really so
it's all that vehicle but i will say
like
tim dillon made a great point he goes
you're depriving the world of the next
real james gandolfini no because he
could have gotten that rule that's good
i think that's a pretty pretty damn good
point but the next james gandolfini
should be his son i mean it's literally
his blood
it's well but we got james gandolfini
out of nowhere okay and now i think
there's someone who's maybe his age
who's been training though too so i'm
you know i thought his son was
the movie was tough for me but i thought
his son was was good but i'm just saying
yeah what if every comment was related
to jerry lewis well we've done that
we've dealt with that we dealt with some
comics who were related to famous
comments oh no that's right and uh they
didn't always do the work yes a lot of
coasting on the looks i don't know who
we're talking about here but we're doing
so much coasting i put my drink on their
head i'll tell you all right
[Music]
that's the singer from haim the baby are
we allowed to do this with that are we
allowed to play
not too much uh all right that's enough
did you maybe give it 20 seconds become
such a hot shot actually oh you already
passed 20. that's what i'm meant to do
whoa this does look like it looks more
wes andersony
it looks like noah bomb back yeah
the screen do you know who i am yeah oh
nice who my girlfriend is
in
we should probably cut it so we don't
get demonetized yeah i mean
uh yeah bradley cooper nice to see him
popping mm-hmm crazy that he's just he
started as a dude from wedding crashers
yeah i know you re-watch that movie and
you're like he was a nobody in that
movie and then you were watching like he
kind of steals a lot of this movie he's
[ __ ] funny and then the hangover he's
the lead yeah so yeah he really came
through and then he's an american hustle
and all that silver linings silver
linings yeah he's a leading man now yeah
he's good man i think he got plugs
really well give it give it an old goo
gonna pick on
yeah i think he's i think he's cheating
yeah what was that called um
yeah he's got old he's got like thinning
hair in the early days yeah and then now
he's got a full beauty on top well steve
carrell got that clear yeah but it looks
it looks good looks good kimmel
seth macfarlane joe mchale
i mean that's like serious hair maybe
not maybe i'm wrong well i actually
photographed him right after wedding
crashers yeah i may have it on my
computer we'll see what his hair looks
like
if you got the money hey [ __ ] it
this is some real detective work what
nice guy or whatever very nice guy yeah
this is it i don't think there's a good
version of it beautiful eyes
oh that's a good good photo man oh thank
you where is that uh an alley on canal
off canal wow
yeah his hair looks great there no it's
okay maybe i'm wrong yeah the
allegations won't stand okay well give
me kimmel and macfarlane and middle a
little you think kimmel has bugs i
guarantee he has plugs
this is what men do we sit around
looking at old hairlines
look at this one i got sidetracked sorry
oh yeah jude lava that's no secret
remember remember jude law uh chris rock
made fun of jude law at the oscars that
year and sean penn came out and he was
like jude law is one of the finest
actors
yeah he's joking
he was so they're so defensive i'm like
jesus [ __ ] christ god you're getting
blown the whole evening a couple jokes
exactly
i'm looking for tom cruise
something like that dude what um
dan
i just read something about like sean
penn i didn't know this that he like
abused the [ __ ] out of madonna
really like look it up beat her up like
tied her to a chair and beat her oh a
little army hammer action we didn't eat
her that's true beat her
um so yeah i'm not finding kimmel hair
plugs at all oh yeah you're losing
yourself mark's making a lot of [ __ ]
allegations here i don't know
it's my screensaver all these guys with
no hair i could show you this [ __ ] in
two seconds
come on what are you typing in jimmy
kimmel hair plugs you got to go jimmy
kimmel
he got his people got that wipe maybe
they did they might have scrubbed it
aha
i mean if you can't find mcfarland
i didn't i think they scrubbed
mcfarland's uh he's a good looking guy
good looking guy underrated looks oh
yeah i mean because he's but that's
isn't that great that your looks are
underrated because that means you're
phony ah good point i mean dude i was i
was watching ted again the other day
it's [ __ ] great
we all watched in vancouver in my hotel
room it was like you me carmen lynch
gary veeder yes so funniest bill hanley
yeah even number two was funny by the
way i was at phil hanley's uh recording
i saw you there two you were
photographing
phil crushed it shout out to phil hanley
it's going to be a great special marcus
russell price who made it look awesome
yeah did a great job love you marcus
proud of both of you guys phil
uh he did such a great job did some
crowd work got loose it was cool to see
comics show up for him like yeah you're
like louise in the back aziz is in the
back it was it was pretty great i'm
proud of him and and you know what i i
went as well and phil after was beaming
which is so rare because comics hate
ourselves we hate our act we're worried
about it that was the one you get one
shot and he was happy with it that's how
you know it's good he was proud and and
it's a long time overdue i mean i think
he should have done this a while ago but
i'm glad he did it until he was like
finally ready but you know uh we got to
take the power back as comics man hell
yeah because you don't want to wait on
people to give you [ __ ] and a lot of
people are waiting and you really you
got to make your own [ __ ] totally i mean
rana there it is ronan's doing one
so list is doing another one stavros is
doing one i mean youtube is the movie's
getting canceled there he's like this
[ __ ] touched me
[Laughter]
damn that's a great who took that photo
salacus wow
look at that scarf
i know right jesus saw a lot of people
it was great too great to be home man
it's the best club after phil's thing i
hung out there like three in the morning
i just couldn't leave i was there on the
street and uh i run to our friend ramy
youssef who i haven't seen forever you
know his old friend i haven't seen him
in ages and we're talking for like you
know 20 minutes on the streets just one
of those like ah dude yeah and uh
immediately some woman we were probably
10 minutes in the comics some woman
walks up to romney with her husband she
goes your show
changed our life and then as that's
happening a crazy guy walks over to me
and he's like let me talk to you dude
this is like the two different new york
experiences you have the one guy getting
blown yeah and this other guy just being
like let me talk to you dude i'm like i
don't have money on me dude
i haven't done my spots yet i don't have
cash yeah that's new york
it's funny because i live
in where in my neighborhood i live by
ronnie chang
and we bump into each other all the time
and he's the sweetest guy
on on the sidewalk he's a sweet guy on
all the time but he's like how are you
how are things going he like puts his
hand on your shoulder talk it in here
yeah buddy but then you see his stand up
and he's like chinese people [ __ ]
smell
all right i love him but he's so good i
text i told him to come on here man and
he he couldn't do i tried to get him uh
i think for the next one he's not
available but he's he said he wants to
come on busy guy and he'll drink with us
oh yeah i've gone to bars with him he'll
don't put him back ronnie chang great i
was going to australia great guy he
brought me like a spreadsheet of all
these restaurants and bars this is where
you need to go you got to go here i mean
he's like he's like a savant when it
comes to where to eat and drink we'd
hoop together in the park a lot too he
was fun to play with because he actually
plays d
he's got discipline i like it you know
yeah a lot of guys you play with they
don't play d they're costing you buckets
that guy goes all in and i respect it
there you go ronnie i had to follow him
the other night at the cellar i he
murdered so hard he made fun of wilson
vince for like 10 minutes it was killer
and i got to get will on here too oh we
got to get will oh man he's he's the
best can you tell us about that hang
after the hanley special because it
seemed pretty epic epic hang it was at
the cellar we had the big long table in
the middle uh hanley's lady is there and
um brian hamilton and godfrey's family's
lady i need a lady i don't think so he
was schmoozing up pretty good with some
brown skinned lady
that that's his type oh yeah that's why
i assumed yeah but i think you might be
right because i was like hey how are you
how do you put up with him she's like
what do you do
like she doesn't get it she's not funny
but maybe that was that yeah
pretty hot nice so i assumed hey phil's
a hot guy she's a hot indian
i figured that was a match
but uh yeah ronan was there list was
there sarah was there it was a great
time yeah and it was a great special so
i i was i was there for like most of the
first special of first taping then i was
like i'll watch the first half of the
second but i was like i couldn't leave i
was like i just want to see the whole
thing yeah so after the show i dance
after the show someone came up to me and
congratulated me
for
warming up the crowd so well
i don't know who that's an insult on you
who's taking these pics they're great
it's me
what do you think he's just pulling
[Laughter]
he's uh he looks uh he looks great there
he looks like he's wearing the fake nose
and glasses
he kind of has like todd phillips vibe
and rode in uh no old school when he
walks in he goes i'm here for the gang
bang oh yeah
he's got that vibe a little bit in this
picture
ted is a throwback to like those uh
filthy raunchy comedies they don't make
him anymore i think you can get away
with it with a toy with a bear you know
because he's like going yeah and all
this [ __ ] and uh it's a bear so it's
cute
yeah i kind of missed that a little bit
oh yeah i said that greg geraldo roast
thing last night and it's like there was
a time where you can kind of just say
whatever and people knew you were like a
good person and kidding and now it's
kind of like
well
what did what did this really mean like
what's you have to think about the
impact of the jokes you're like well
these are just friends joking around
exactly yeah he talked about lorico
martin's tits for two seconds i don't
remember that one oh it was great he's
like
larry come on you got big tits i mean if
i titty [ __ ] you uh you might not even
see me
you're the only person here his tits are
bigger than patrice's
wow but now that you could just clip
that be like that's offensive to women
it's like ah it's just a roast we're
[ __ ] around yeah there's no cell
phones back then it was it was just fun
yeah it's crazy to see footage like that
isn't it because you're just like oh wow
i guess this is uh
this is like actually videotaped yeah
because there was no like people just
videoed you know
yeah i got yelled at this was a like a
poignant moment i was doing a show in uh
vancouver this weekend and some lady was
like that's inappropriate and a guy on
the other end goes yeah it's comedy oh
and it was like whoa these two worlds
and this guy just kind of nailed it in
one sentence and it shut it all down it
was kind of cool
what was it joe
he's like some pity [ __ ] a [ __ ]
we're like jesus christ
[Laughter]
titty [ __ ] [ __ ] is my favorite
country song
um but yeah it was just a nice moment we
uh yeah we
we had someone with the seller last
night who was like you know they have
the the bags you have to put the phone
and the bags oh they don't like that
well yeah this woman she's like trying
to open her bag she's on her phone and
i'm like i wouldn't care if i didn't
hear her talk i'd given her like three
or four jokes where i've talked over her
at a certain point i'm like all right
miss come on and she goes i need to i
need to take this call what and i was
just like of course like white lady
let's do this like i'm teasing her and
then like and i was like who are you she
goes i'm her partner so i'm like oh my
god like you're both annoying i'm like
[ __ ] on both of them i'm just like
i'm like i'm like how are you both this
and she goes continue i'm like who's the
shitty one you're both yeah so i'm kind
of trashing them and then she walks out
like in a huff and i find out she like
works with like teenage suicide
prevention i'm like
wow
but then i'm also like no one of these
kids want to kill themselves
they know her like she's like i'm on
calm like then why are you at the show
i'm on call
jeez some kids all fell off a building
now because you're trying to get a
zinger in get out of here
i need a good laugh
it's also weird to hear like she's
taking the call in the hall she's just
i'm like killing up there she's just
he's a huge laugh she's like life is
worth living
i'm like so i'm with this chick the
other night anyway please
you ever [ __ ] on a girl's chest don't do
it don't do it
where are you
oh yeah that's uh it's it's a weird time
but yeah just seeing those old clips i
watched the carlin video just the other
day just popped up my youtube and he was
like you know what i call feminist come
catcher
and you know women are laughing and
you're like yeah it was comedy it was
[ __ ] around
we could analyze everything and make it
seem horrible and this is bad because of
this and history but it was jokes he
opened one of his specials with he ever
noticed someone who's uh yeah everyone
is a pro-life people the people that you
want to [ __ ] to begin with you're like
oh my god so good so good so good what
about um
yeah i mean that was that was classic
oh yeah and that's what we grew up on so
then like when we get into comedy then
you know you start getting better and
and more established and then it just
changes so it's kind of like yeah and
we're all about evolving you know we're
not trying to say the n word up there
but it's also like
come on let's meet in the middle
yeah i know it is weird where it's like
the line i mean that's cause then your
jokes are inevitably gonna age poorly if
you're trying to walk that line yes not
all of them but some of them you're
gonna look back like all right well i i
can't say those anymore right right
you're scrambling you're at a corporate
you're scrambling your head for material
like can't do rape jokes anymore yeah
speaking of which it is corporate season
yeah you ready for those i did a private
event on saturday after a knicks game in
which my brother and i nearly got into a
fight whoa
whoa
let's hear it well i'll tell the short
version of it basically we're at the
game it's a one of the worst games ever
my it was a 5 p.m game i had before the
private event thing so
my brother is like he hits me up he's
like let's go to the next game and i was
like it's 5 p.m i could i'm like i'm
tired then i have a couple coffees i'm
like [ __ ] it let's do it
so we go it's got to be the worst first
quarter of basketball i've ever seen
right unbelievably bad that like
nick scored 13 points it was unwatchable
which in the modern nba is crazy they're
playing terribly
this guy is just so [ __ ] annoying
behind us he's drunk as [ __ ] long island
just like the worst type of long island
dude yeah and um
that sounded like i wasn't racist but
you people are the worst type of people
but he's like you know
pinching people he's like flicking hair
and [ __ ] yeah and uh
oh the stories have gone mad if you're
looking for them as an archive of them
somewhere oh yeah why [ __ ] you gotta go
i can i can text him to you yeah you're
just looking up this is the funniest
thing too i used to have a show on msg
so i'm just thinking if i fight this
dude it's gonna be a headline like
disgraced former msg race dragged down
by security
you know yeah so yeah let me i'll send
you though thank you if you want to play
yeah please try text them your email
text is fine all right let me pull these
up so
um
this guy was [ __ ] with us the whole
show
all right
so your show's at nine or eight
because if you got a if you go to a five
o'clock game the game's gonna be what
three hours
yeah about and the shows that i we go on
at ten it's oh okay okay so it worked
out perfectly dina uh grabbed me we did
the gig together
and uh all right sally i'm sending them
to you thank you and you can go in this
order i think okay this guy's [ __ ]
with us
and
like he said he flicked your hat my head
so kind of [ __ ] so these other guys
are pretty annoying in our section too
but they're not as bad as this guy and
like look man i've gone to games my
whole life i can deal with annoying but
these dudes am i so can my brother but
these dudes are particularly bad you
know so anyway start here uh
whatever order they came in let me see
yeah that that works i think oh boy
is that your brother
oh that's the guy
[ __ ]
that's me going in the morning and
[ __ ] because he poured a beer on my
brother
[ __ ] up then he flicked the back of my
head what i saw and i saw his hand and
he goes who's this other guy what so so
that's when i [ __ ] my brother [ __ ]
snatched my brother's like like you got
a problem yeah pour a beer on me that's
fine well that's the end hold on that's
no don't don't go there yet that's the
last one come on
second one this one yeah maybe this one
i don't
yeah i don't know try them
that's him getting kicked out all right
bye-bye what a [ __ ] face
[ __ ] with him jerk off yeah and then
and then so then security pulled
and this idiot doesn't realize you get
out of this idiot doesn't realize it but
the [ __ ] out bye-bye
bye-bye
he's a punk guy yeah so then he like
he's being a [ __ ] everyone the
section hates him that guy next to him
he was pinching the whole everyone hated
him wow so then
then secure you can play the last one
the other one you played before last
where they're chanting so the best part
is we're in the section
and they pull me out to be like what
happened whatever
and
people
i guess follow me on instagram and the
thing so they see it so people in the
section are chanting free sam
free sam because they don't want me to
get kicked out and i didn't they just
talked to me for like a second they
kicked that guy out that's good did he
ever take a swing or make a move no i
was like i was and it sucks my neck is
so bad right now but i was [ __ ] ready
to go dude yeah my brother was we were
[ __ ] fired up
play the last and play the free sam one
the bash brothers i mean it must be this
one no no no no it's out of order yeah
so go up up yeah i think it's that one
where i'm smiling
okay
we'll see not that one this one yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
and uh he didn't have any friends near
him he had one other guy who sucked too
they both suck what is that people suck
yeah and i said to him i said to him
many times like i was being very
respectful before it got to this i'm not
doing i'm not videoing it right
until i said hey man
i'm here with my brother i got in his
face i said you're ruining sibling
bonding right here
i don't get a lot of nights off and
you're [ __ ] ruining this yes and i
said you're ruining a night out with my
brother and once you [ __ ] once you [ __ ]
with someone's family it gets a little
like i can't fight but i'll [ __ ]
i'll throw down
you don't [ __ ] with my you don't [ __ ]
with family
no what a pip squeak too he's such a
twerp that guy he was a [ __ ] let's hope
he doesn't sue us
yeah can we get in trouble for that matt
should we blur out his face there also
peter's your screen's off screen's off
again also i yeah i mean i already
posted on into the story
yeah yeah
all right well we're giving this guy a
full you want to come in talk about it
and uh you're not what do you do
no we bring them in sally puts a burlap
sack
this video here i have made a mistake
yeah we'll get a rusty knife and
all right we do we have to blur his face
all right all right you know what i
wouldn't that's the thing sometimes you
ever post like a video where guys like a
real piece of [ __ ] heckler i had a guy
run on stage once and [ __ ] with me and
then i posted the video and i got a lot
of views and he was like can you please
take this down i'm being recognized from
work and i was like uh no this is the
valuable life lesson that i'm providing
to you yes now you're getting heckled at
work
[ __ ] you blow me yeah uh wait what were
you talking about before this i don't
know oh i had something damn but good
glad street justice [ __ ] oh the
corporate yeah how was the corporate it
was great it was like a private it
wasn't in court it was like a private
event it was someone's 40th birthday
party and they were really cool was it
like a hotel ballroom they rented out
open bar very nice yeah nice had you
know i heard dina crushing up top and i
was like that's a good sign good sign so
uh you know uh yeah they were they were
very cool
all right yeah how about you what are
you doing well i i got some on the books
and i just have the most
notorious horror stories from
corporates yeah i mean i've bombed
everywhere but corporates it's a special
type of bomb you just think about the
money you're going to make that's what
mullany said to me once that's keeps you
going i saw him with the seller after i
bombed a corporate and i was like how
are you like i'm doing really badly just
to the corporate goes you just think
about what you're going to buy in my
head i'm like we're making way more
money yeah yeah yeah
i'm thinking about buying like a certain
bottle of scotch
he's adding a layer to his apartment
right he's like i'll get a sex swing for
olivia munn
speaking of can we get uh some spots
uh read some spots oh yeah we should do
an ad here all right voice of reason
over here
all right all right honey
hey hey
we might be drunk as brought to you by
honey our online shopping is about to
increase what the holiday is right
around the corner folks you got to get
gifts you got to get knickknacks you got
to get food drinks and you won't have
time to hunt for any deals and looking
for the best price but honey wants to be
your magical shopping elf and bring the
savings directly to you honey is a free
browser extension that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your cart it's
simple when you check out the honey
button drops down and all you have to do
is click apply coupons wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
you can find for the site if honey finds
a working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop it's a pretty genius idea why not
do it tell them how fatty hey man if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out on free savings
it's literally free and installs in just
a few seconds and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this podcast baby get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
drunk that's joinhoney.com
drunk
we might be drug is also brought to you
by lucy are we doing lucy yeah let's do
it we might be drunk is also brought to
you by lucy lucy the company that made
nicotine gum tastes good is back with
their latest product lucy nicotine
capsule pouches hey that's fun
everybody knows smoking's uh not good
for you we're all trying to get off of
it
smoking's tough hard to quit some people
read all books about it and everything
get hypnotized but these pouches bring
you pure synthetic nicotine with the
satisfaction you expect with no tobacco
each path comes each pouch comes with a
flavor ball that can crush
for an extra burst of any of their
exclusive flavors spearmint mango and
cool cider cool cider sounds kind of
good yeah and since they've thought of
everything each pouch also includes
coconut oil to provide a soft fluffy
texture that enhances the flavor and
doesn't dry out your mouth try them in
four or eight milligrams lucy nicotine
was started to help nicotine users find
a definitive option and feel better
about the ways they consume nicotine
with the nicotine capsule pouches
they've added another tool to your kit
kill it it's uh 2021 don't compromise
when you're choosing your nicotine
products go with the newest tobacco-free
options from lucy we might be drunk
listeners go to lucy.co
and use promo code drunk to get 20 off
your order of lucy nicotine capsule
pouches or any other lucy's products
that's lucy.co
use promo code drunk at checkout also i
have to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains
non-tobacco nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical go to lucy.co and be
sure to use the promo code drunk yeah
give me a peeve man i got a big peeve
right up your ass coming at you here hit
me
how about this yeah underwear
with no
opening dude i i said this in the last
on a recent app i hate it it happens
it's happened to me twice i bought it
because you don't even think that they
would make [ __ ] i know like what kind of
monster you think
by the way you think i'm just like
pulling my whole balls and dick out when
i i'm just blowing the dick out yeah one
of my special needs nine-year-old i got
my [ __ ] pants down by my ankles i got
my underwear down i'm at the urinal the
the airport like a [ __ ] 12 year old i
hate it give me a flap someone's kicking
your shoe because you think
you're giving him a signal i mean what
the hell is going on yeah they're doing
the tap you know the gay uh the gay code
but uh no i hate the no flap i'm pulling
the whole thing down my dick's 12 inches
so i got to flop it over it's the whole
thing but yeah i hate the no flap what
year is it it's 2021. well they think
it's like a trendy option but i think
it's horrible i don't i mean i shout out
i mean we're not even doing everything
but sheath does it right man
i like places that actually know what
the [ __ ] they're doing and and uh
i i went to gap and i was at like a like
a discount type store and i was like oh
these look fine i didn't even look
you gotta look you gotta look
yeah and can we get uh all we talk about
is body positivity and big is beautiful
every man on underwear package is like
uh brad pitt and fight club i know how
about a dad bod yeah i know just to feel
better it's a little annoying it's a
little annoying but hey that's what's
cool about being a guy we can take it
you don't see us complaining but uh just
saying it's a lot of uh a lot of look at
these oh that's uh marky mark come on he
doesn't get much hotter than that why is
he grabbing his dick in that one yeah
he's a tough guy he beat him
but what does that mean to grab your i
mean that make you tough you're like let
me [ __ ] grab there like holy [ __ ]
that guy grabbed his dick yeah i think
what won't he grab michael jackson
started that i guess you know the hee
hee i remember that
which uh i never got but it just caught
on people loved it
yeah i guess it was like edgy i don't
know yeah richard pryor that great jokes
like white guy's like why do you guys
always grab your things he's like you
took everything else [ __ ]
yeah what is with these heads i mean
these guys are chiseled they're adonises
even kramer and the seinfeld underwear
adam like he's got a pretty good body
pretty good body yeah
like it's weird i remember alibel uh
really funny combo we've never seen him
he's got a documentary out al lubel
would just strip down naked on stage
what i remember i used to have a bar
show and he would just take all he had
great he was like a dry one-liner guy
and then he would just like
he would just get naked he'd go down
with his underwear and people would be
like what the [ __ ] is he do it at the
seller what yeah and then and then he
would be like you guys are surprised
because you're expecting me to have a
really bad body and it's not that bad
and people were like yeah yeah wow that
is weird big j used to get down to his
uh skivvies on stage that was his closer
so funny yeah i mean that was back in
the day when you were new and you were
just
grasping at straws i need any kind of
reaction
most people go blue he went uh he went
naked i got it i got a uh yeah what do
you got in the pv let's see what i got
um
man yeah you know what else is a decent
body as conan surprisingly good body oh
does he i mean he's sheet white but uh
he's got he's got abs really yeah
conan's ripped look at that
wow
ben stiller too it's like oh oh yeah
it's almost like two ripped it's almost
like dude you're a comedian i know he
lets you know it too it's every movie he
gets you know shirtless look at that
that's a solid sixer
yeah but it's like kind of weird with
ben stiller's like if i can meet the
parents and a speedo and a six-pack and
i'm like did you write this one in
exactly i think you just wanted us to
see how ripped you look yep heavyweights
that one yeah uh zoolander obviously
he's always uh getting shirtless yeah
you're right you know who else likes
being naked a lot as a brian cranston
really well i just feel like in breaking
bad he was in his tiny whities for the
first half of the whole show does he
like that or is that because if it's one
show i'm not going to blame the actor
every movie you're in i'm kind of like
maybe it's you yeah and ben stiller does
write these
i mean heavyweights he was literally a
bodybuilder and then i think in
dodgeball he was ripped too until the
end is he still with christine taylor
she's underrated they might have tried
to come back together
look at that one oh adam driver man
looks like a centaur that's crazy i know
what is with him women he's the ugliest
man on the planet and the ladies love
he's not ugly adam driver what are you
kidding he looks like the scream mask
look how long his face is he's hideous
yeah but he's he's unique looking he's
not ugly okay
if you're like a confident talented
unique i mean is owen wilson ugly he's
like a unique guy i think he's all right
look but you put adam if he was a
cashier at cvs you'd you'd go yikes
halloween's in town i'm just saying we
put them on a pedestal all right
do you think dustin hoffman will be
cleaning cleaning up as a cashier i'm
not saying he's handsome either but uh
but you put ryan gosling as a cashier
like was a good looking cashier i know
but but then what is every actor
supposed to look like ryan gosling no
i'm just going to be born
attractive and unattractive i think he's
unattractive
women they love him
well he is 6'5 or something as well also
an ex-marine and an ex-marine and a hell
of an actor
yeah so i'm saying he's a catch i'm just
saying he's traditionally annie bang
lena dunham on a show so women are like
he doesn't see
yeah doesn't see i'm not gonna finish
the joke
he doesn't see
color it's an open-minded fellas yeah um
let's see what i got i got okay there's
one that's good acting people i've done
them
few worse uh feelings when you take a
[ __ ] in public and the second you sit
you put your ass on this on the thing
like not in public in a public restroom
i'm not sure i'm not bending over in the
starbucks but uh you sit on the toilet
and the second your butt hits the seat
someone aggressively nods
the aggressive knocker and you're like
i'm gonna be quick but you gotta have my
back here yes yes i hate if i'm taking a
[ __ ] in public it's an emergency right
right and at the aggressive knock it
tightens your butthole you're like i
need to be relaxed here and you're doing
the opposite
i hate that and i hate when you ever
have this one when you're in a stall and
you just hear like the
the guy's just you're like it's locked
deal you gotta you gotta accept the fact
that it's locked they're like twisted
and turn and you're like it's locked
buddy
every every door should have the
airplane vacant uh no uh occupied things
that would be nice good call
yeah because we've all had that like
timid guy in front of us in the bathroom
line who's like someone's in there and
you're like it's been 20 minutes are you
sure and then they're like it's open
you're like you right you weak
[ __ ] also what's up with the
crack in the door it's it's like it's a
full quarter inch oh you mean a stall
and a stall yeah i hate it you see that
wandering eye you're like all right
i'm trying to read you see if they see
him lift a camera phone you're like
please
yeah no more vulnerable moment than
[ __ ] yeah
try and there are a couple of comedy
movies where the guy's [ __ ] and the
water shoots up oh what is that is that
uh caddyshack i don't know maybe animal
house because you know it's gonna be a
bad movie when they're just like we need
a laugh scene right here like what if
the [ __ ] water shoots up and hits
everyone in the face they're like that's
it
that's the scene yeah that's true
remember the first time you saw bill
murray biting to that uh payday that was
pretty jarring was it a baby ruth i
think oh baby ruth yeah good call payday
would have been even grosser than inside
it's a lot of nuts
yeah those nuts don't break down need
this corn corn doesn't break down in
your system what do you think about uh
a baby ruth what do you rank i love baby
root the class love it love it more than
payday for sure payday's too much nuts
too much nuts we got it yeah baby root's
a nice uh mix
yeah yeah what does that move with the
[ __ ] i guarantee there's a montage
of shitty or [ __ ] howard and kumo
there's the diarrhea scene oh and the
the hot women with diarrhea or you're
like yes
and uh
dumb and dumber of course oh that's a
classic classic
[Laughter]
he was very intimidated to take that
role he said because it because the gym
character jim carrey yeah he's amazing
in it yeah jeff daniels is great man
great so good he can do it all news raid
not news radio mushroom newsroom ugh i
couldn't stand that show it's a little
much it's like literally the most smug
liberal [ __ ] i've ever seen in my life
like the like we're doing the lord's
work yeah opening monologue you could
just you know that sorkin was jerking
off while he wrote it it was just like
i'm [ __ ] awesome at this yeah he's
like you know we need to take we need to
be accountable
the media needs to be accountable he's
like yes we do i'm [ __ ] i'm writing
i'm going to show it's going to change
the world yeah sorkin really blows
himself on a lot i mean look he's great
like social network i loved that was
incredible i think he did a few good men
yeah he did and moneyball and moneyball
was great oh great dialogue yeah but
like he really i mean dude i love sports
night back in the day oh that was an
underrated [ __ ] great show i think it
was too smart for the room oh it was
like a non it was on like a it was on
like abc and there was no laugh track
and i think people were like what
before television was smart
yeah good point
yeah no it was it was a different tone
as well i mean it was it was a really
good show but uh
you know
he definitely
he falls victim i think some i mean like
we're talking about one of the greatest
screenwriters of all that we're
criticizing one of the greatest
screenwriters ever but i do feel like
that
you feel the smugness in the writing
sometimes oh yeah oh yeah we get it
you're great take it easy those
characters just annoyed the [ __ ] out of
me yeah like all of them annoyed me
right ah
yeah sometimes it's too much sometimes i
just want to pull back i watched an m
night shyamalan ding-dong movie on the
uh on the plane which one old is it good
ah it's not great but let me guess the
twist is that he's like he's young
basically these people go to a beach and
the beach you age like insanely rapidly
oh yeah are they tricked to go to the
beach how do they get to that beach
beach is called hollywood oh my god
you're oh yeah you turn 18 into old yeah
they're at malibu i mean they're at a
resort and then the guy goes you want to
see a real beach and they throw all
these uh rich people in a van they bring
them to this beach it's beautiful they
swim and then they realize like wow my
six-year-old looks like he's 15. and
then
the dog my daughter was five now she
looks interesting
great but what's in it for the guy to
bring these people to a cursed beach
they do experiments on them
i don't want to give too much away
but it's like epstein's island he was
18. get out gotta go
back on that jet yeah yeah those girls
grew up quick
but yeah yeah it's fun fun movie but
i don't know it's just
m night shyamalan i feel like it's
running off one movie or maybe two
uh the one movie being the sixth sense
yep that was a great movie
i mean it was the talk of uh all it's
all america talk about i see dead people
it was every punch line you know i
didn't see it coming my friend said he
knew he didn't know about what about uh
i mean yeah what's the other one the
signs i heard is pretty good
yeah you never saw it it's pretty good
unbreakable's pretty good yeah but it's
just a slow decline
he seems to be making the same movie
over and over again
yeah
capturing that well i think i got known
everyone's known for a thing and he got
known for the twist and you almost get
stuck yeah mm-hmm
yep yep yep
m night shyamalan though it's just such
a it's such a good name like you hear
that it's it's like all right we gotta
go see that it's so recognized yeah what
else has he he did the happening that
was supposed to be terrible he did the
devil remember that one that was in an
elevator
[Music]
the devil was in the elevator with like
six people killing him one by one devil
in the elevator yeah is that about a
fart
and i remember watching the trailer in
theaters and
people were like laughing at how bad it
was and then when his name came up just
uproarious laughter because everyone
knew like this is bad this is bad and
then when they was confirmed how bad
this was
huge laugh wow
i love new yorkers man they're so
cynical and obnoxious like you're
literally laughing so i mean yeah it
might stop but this dude probably worked
really hard on it it's just so funny to
look at someone's work and be like
that's true
that's true but those movie experiences
are i saw iron man in midtown in times
square day it came out it was me and
like eight nerds they all brought their
action figures i was like i'm going to
experience this let me go all in when
that [ __ ] head helmet went
they all went
popcorn's flying
that was fun i mean is there like you
can you think of a better dude to cast
as iron man than robert downey jr he
nailed it that that's like
that's the one time you're like yeah
he's got to be like no one would have
been as good no no tony stark perfect
perfect yeah and then he made 12 of them
after that 12.
but fun in the theater i saw american
pie in the theater with the famous uh
when he [ __ ] the pie some guy somebody
goes he tore that [ __ ] up killed dude
it's fun when when you're at a fun
comedy and you got a funny guy in there
yeah yes
the problem is when you get the guy
who's not funny who keeps going for it i
know i know you know it's a great
feeling though i got heckled my balls
off in canada this weekend just uh it
was just where were you in canada
vancouver vancouver yeah the house of
commons why'd you get heckled so much ah
i think they drink a lot out there you
know they're all nice and hey how you
doing hey yeah sorry so they drink and
it all comes out yeah you're right it's
gotta even out somewhere did did you
were they packed houses packed yeah we
sold it out but uh a lot of booze bags
and also uh they've been locked down
pretty good so i think they're finally
out and they're really going for it they
spread the vaccine in canada out you get
like your first dose and then you get
your second dose in like six months it
was something insane yeah yeah it didn't
make a lot of sense they're still weird
over there i had to get to the united
states for getting us vaccines hell yeah
uh also our president's not wearing
blackface hey all right but
also they got a real problem with their
indigenous uh we'll get into it yeah
yeah but either way i got heckled and uh
ah i can't remember my point
[ __ ]
what we're talking about
ah
we were saying something
uh
hecklers hecklers
we were on a train
m night
ah i lost it
tell us about being heckled what was
that well that's what i was saying but i
don't know what the heck was like where
how did they oh [ __ ] in my mouth i can't
think of what i was gonna say heckle
have another drink one gin and tonic or
whatever vodka soda
ah
it'll come to me it'll come to me
but yeah got heckled damn it
play the tape back matt what the hell
was i talking about [ __ ]
i had a whole thing it was gonna break
open a whole discussion that's god we're
sloppy yeah
what uh noon we're hammered what
what uh
what was it
we were talking about movies and night
shyamalan twists yeah yeah
heckled in vancouver they got a problem
with indigenous
vaccine
wow damn it we are drunk we might be
[ __ ]
ah i had some i'll see if i have any
other peeves you know i always got
peeved give me a pee maybe it'll come
back to me it was a point i was getting
two give up
let's start with you have a bit mark do
you want to go to bits i got a bit it's
not great yeah i got one that i need
more on but it's i will do that in a sec
but all right um
okay there's one i got
i'm in the elevator and i'm holding two
really heavy bags
and the woman uh she asked me to hit the
floor
i'm holding too bad they hit her floor
oh she tells me i think she's like four
and i'm just like holding two i'm
holding too everybody you're gonna make
me do this [ __ ] yeah
huh yeah weird i would think a hannibal
burris is bit you remember he had a bit
where he gets something a woman gets in
the elevator
and uh she's like five please and he
goes [ __ ] this ain't mad men oh
damn
[Music]
damn that that that hits that's
hilarious yeah well in this woman's
defense
um in coveted times i'm not reaching
across people to hit my elevator button
i asked them to do it even though no
matter what i'm holding what they're
holding
i'm like now i gotta put my bags i'm
gonna do the elbows it was a whole thing
you know what you do in that situation
you you gotta play it up you gotta go
and really make her feel bad like you
know drop on a loaf of bread and you're
like oh geez then you hit the four you
gotta really let her know that that was
a [ __ ]
to do
but yeah that's that's crazy
and you hit it you hit the button the
butt with an elbow i did yeah i got it
all right i was annoyed but i did it
that's a pet peeve of mine i stayed in
this uh hotel it was like the 28th floor
the view was amazing but the elevator is
an issue every day it's like i hate high
floors yeah you're going down now you
got to stop at 15. stop at 13. you pick
people up stop at eight stop at six and
you're like man this is it takes forever
to get up there i i i
hate a high floor people think it's like
luxurious i mean i want to know i can
get the [ __ ] out same same and i'm a big
stairs guy i'll take those uh fire
stairs all day long just because hey you
want to get a little blood flowing
because you're on the road eating
hoagies and drinking booze all night
yeah so uh yeah i was taking the stairs
every now and then
yeah uh another peeve
how about this i had the guy do the side
cut
in line oh i [ __ ] it's unacceptable
unacceptable there's no side cut there's
cutting it's cutting it's cutting what's
a side cut all right well we got a line
at the airport and then you see this you
know we're all single file you see this
one guy
trying to just transition into it live
side cut toward the end it's it's more
understandable but you can't sock it to
the middle or the front it was a middle
side and you know you got the velvet
rope going down and the velvet rope
stopped he waited right by the end of
that velvet open
and then you want to say something but
you don't want to say something because
you don't want to be the the [ __ ] guy
but
brutal
yeah i don't like yeah that that bugs
the hell out of me i i don't like
confrontation but i'll [ __ ] do it
yeah you had a guy thrown out of a
knicks game what are you talking about i
don't like it i don't like that but i
will tell you that fourth quarter was
[ __ ] wonderful yeah the my brother
and i were like i think we needed that i
think we need to get we had all this
pent up rage from the game and now you
know the knicks came back thank god oh
yeah yeah but yeah this uh the side cut
guy had some trouble with his uh ticket
so he kept going like
you know wasn't going and then i went
around and i was like beep and i was
like all right that's how you do it
that's how you do it had my ticket ready
there
yeah man i mean i'm with you dude i it's
you showed him i showed him i don't you
know what i don't like when people do
something here's a here's a peeve of
mine when people do something shitty to
you and then the next time you see them
they act like they didn't do something
shitty to you and you should be happy to
see them
yeah that's that's associated that to me
drives me nuts it happened to me at the
seller the other night this guy wrote a
book on the comedy cellar he wrote a
really shitty chapter on me and he sent
me sent me the book thinking i would
think it was good
a whole chapter [ __ ] on you no it
was like a paragraph he reduced it to a
paragraph but i was a part of this
chapter and it was just like what's the
book
i don't remember what it's called i
don't want to say his name yeah i put
him on blast but i mean he wrote i he
wrote me uh he he was going over my
alligator joke the one about the baby
that got eaten by the alligator because
he was talking about people getting mad
about jokes and stuff and i and i gave
him i talked to him for so many hours on
the phone cause i was like i thought it
was gonna be a big book on the seller
and he reduces what i say to like one
paragraph and it was about me being like
i could bring the book in it was about
me being like
uh i might have thrown it out but uh it
was about me being uh anxious about
trusting a journalist to to write about
this with uh care
um and here we go
wow so he acted all like it was good to
see you and i said i think your book
stunk all right and i was like well at
least we wrote about me stung some of
the other stuff i think was okay but
yeah uh you know i was pretty i was
pretty bummed out by that what did he
say he was like well you know i'm a big
fan i was like well the next time show
it in the writing yes i gave you a lot
of my time i'm having a lot of that on
the road the fan i had a guy with a mark
norman t-shirt and he just
no laugh i'm like you're you're my
support you're not even laughing isn't
that weird it's weird some people have
just a bad laugh face true some people
have like a bad listen face and i think
that's the problem and then they're like
this whole time they're like
yeah and then you make a joke and like
yeah resting [ __ ] they call it yeah
yeah and then they'll be like
tuesdays we might be drunk you're like
why are you ruining the show now you're
so pent up and excited that you're just
yelling stuff and i think in a weird way
they think like i'm gonna go see sam
we'll have we'll hang out we'll interact
and you're like it's still a show
pretend it's les miz les mis baby you
know give me something the song of angry
melbourne what the song of angry men
brother what's that the layman's do you
hear the people sing singing the song of
angry men
mm-hmm great tune great great music
that's a real dad musical mm-hmm every
dad's like we should go to les
miserables i love later because because
it's a musical but it's like you feel
kind of it's like french revolution i
feel like yeah
right about stealing bread and [ __ ]
that's a great musical great it's a
great great the whole thing john valjean
number 120601
it's classic i might have made up those
numbers but yeah i took a humanities
class in high school and we learned all
about musicals and it was the best class
it's crazy people [ __ ] on musicals but
you get a good one man
throwing little guys and dolls man
too fun hell yeah bye bye birdie don't
get me started never seen that one oh
it's great it's great i like that song
good good musical oklahoma what's that
is that that's the song isn't that a
song bye-bye birdie it's the musical i
know but isn't there a song in there
called that oh yeah that is the lead
like the main song bye
bye
birdie boy see we got range on this part
yeah we can go from uh eating ass to
musicals so i saw this is i guess is my
wreck i saw this movie uh it's called at
long last with burt reynolds oh wow
madeleine khan sybil shepard i think
it's like 19 other that's 1975.
it's a musical
huh reynolds in a musical yeah let's
play a couple can you sing
he talks to it but
i want to see this
it's funny it's a funny musical
madeleine khan is really funny cass had
three beers and then ate the glass wow
it's actually not bad
i think it's all cole porter songs
so they're gonna be good
i don't know this looks horrible
i'm telling you it was funny all right
so funny that this is like the dude from
deliverance yeah
yeah right there's like all right you
can do deliverance and then you're gonna
put on a monkey suit
i guess it's kind of like uh your brando
in a musical that you like to do grab
pull that up pull up there's go mid song
of brando singing luck be a lady and
guys and doll the funniest can we hear
your impression first the fact that well
the fact that brando gets the lead in a
musical over sinatra is the all-time fun
oh diddy oh my god he's he's uh
he's skye masterson which is the lead
and and sinatra's nathan detroit yeah
and he can't he talks through it he's
like they call you laney lock
that's pretty good give me the brush
oh yeah that's already bad you might
forget your manner
but it's so bad that it's kind of good
yeah
like bob dylan
[Music]
where is he from with that voice
is he in new york i think he's a new
yorker i'll look it up
be a lady tonight
sing it sam luck being a lady tonight
[Music]
sinatra saying this song his whole
[ __ ] career you know because it's
because he didn't get the second in this
movie yeah you know his whole career
because he's like that's how you [ __ ]
sing it dude
damn that's a good musical comedy guys
and dolls it's hilarious yeah it's just
guys being degenerates and and like all
of it's just gambling and like the
premise is like he's trying to bang this
uh woman i mean it's like some of those
scenes
they're hilarious to watch now he's just
trying to get her drunk
and and she's like this tastes like a
milkshake he's like sure it does have
another milkshake
just keeps ordering her milkshakes damn
i've never seen it it's pretty great you
know the song isn't it like uh and the
devil will drag you under from the sharp
lapel of your checkered coat sit down
sit down sit down sit down sit down
you're rocking the boat dude
you know that one yeah i do know that
one yeah you know the tunes all right
it's classic man he was handsome brenda
was hot as [ __ ] so hot would you
i'd [ __ ] him in the ass you would yeah
he's handsome dude young brando's hot oh
what are you getting the hottest old
brando uh yeah he really 180. i'm gonna
get sd platformed here but this is
brando sucking a dick whoa
that's my dick
that's a black dick it is i wonder if
that's richard pryor's
actually they figured out who it is i
could look it up but i don't remember
because they uh they had a hot hot thing
for a while brando really knew how to
push the butt i mean so
i don't know if that's real that doesn't
look real to me he he set the yeah
you've given matt peters a ton of work
here he's getting very annoying that was
a ball shot he also
you couldn't find kimmel's hairline you
got brando's ball sack exposed in two
seconds what what is remember we sent
the native american woman to yeah get
the oscar for him he wasn't actually
native american she was an actress
oh stealing a roll from a native
american exactly and then brando had
play i think he played like an asian
person one movie there's some [ __ ] we
were like this is not i know your
heart's in the right place but some of
this [ __ ] is weird yeah yeah i think he
went a little bat [ __ ] he went a little
nutty i i watched that val kilmer dock
and he said uh on the set uh brando was
a little little off i read so i was uh i
read sydney lumet's book uh uh
on making movies and he said um
that brando he's like he's an incredible
actor but he just tortures directors
yeah and he would do two takes early on
to see if you were good like he would he
would uh do two early takes and one he
would be doing it in his mind the right
way and the other and the other one he
would do in a more artificial shallow
way and if the director liked the second
way he would give nothing to the movie
because he was like i'm not going to
waste my talents on this guy who doesn't
get me so he would like [ __ ] with you
and play games with you yeah so you get
the great brando if he thought you were
great aha
interesting so is he is he from new york
omaha nebraska wow
midwest boy but he got but he he honed
his chops in new york
yeah he could have some native american
in him stella
yeah
omaha yeah good point he's great because
that's [ __ ] great yeah yeah streetcar
is a masterpiece eli kazan he named
names
he did he did name names not a fan of
that no
he did what he had to do i guess
i guess arthur miller he's all over that
duck oh i gotta i gotta watch that dog
still pretty good i mean i don't know if
i'm gonna get to now that i got this
criterion set up though god damn i'm
fired up oh
we got criterion we do oh we got
everything
stolen cable oh
yeah
all right
what do you think mark's gonna like not
hit a fastball over the plate yeah well
i mean i i didn't say the name okay but
yeah it's pretty great little uh they
know his name
they know your name but i'm not saying
the name of the uh the service salamanca
yes should we do a bit let's do a bit i
got i got [ __ ] also make sure to email
us to the patreon at we might be drunk
pod at gmail.com that's we might be
drunk pod gmail.com and leave us a nice
review on the podcast app or apple
whatever you're doing hell yeah and see
us on the road we'll plug the dates at
the end of the show but make sure to see
us on the road what do you got mark all
right all right now this is a talk about
a half baked lucy goosey
not much here and i need your help
so i was look i was reading the thing
about the the founding fathers
and
i got to tell you these guys were
tough men tough men grew up poor
became presidents
uh been shot at the duel in the street
yeah uh they talk [ __ ]
they're like rappers fred four funds
with the the original rapper wood grill
rough riders
there's a lot a lot of comparisons there
uh always complaining about slaves
no
but they've been shot at like teddy
roosevelt got shot at in and kept doing
a speech remember that that's almost
like a 50 cent thing
it's interesting yeah it's like like oh
you want to [ __ ] i love the the rapper
like the angle of like duels and stuff
like oh you want to go let's [ __ ]
you're like jesus christ what are you
like running for office or tupac yeah i
mean like yeah like hamilton and burr
headed out in the street yeah gunfight
yeah so it's it's like east coast west
coast rivalry and that's part of why
hamilton's so popular he died young
no like tupac and biggie
yeah
well known some people hate them some
people love them but yeah i don't know
this seems like a lot there with the
rapping my only fear is that hamilton is
rapping
oh that's clever
yeah but that's so that maybe you have
to bring that around i mean hamilton
never but then yeah hmm yeah but it's
mostly comes from teddy roosevelt he's
in a thing called the rough riders he's
been shot
you know he gives a full performance
he's manly he's like tough as hell he's
big yeah
some of them are in a wheelchair
are there rappers in wheelchairs
no
just their homies
but yeah i don't know presidents were
the original rappers could be something
there's something there about
coming from not coming from the streets
yes
they all came from nothing a lot of them
grew up poor
they made it
they'll shoot you yeah they'll shoot you
in the face
oh um they don't smoke weed they don't
uh like paying their taxes
we had a revolution because we didn't
like to pay taxes good point to the
british point yeah
i like that lincoln was against slavery
there's something here i'll play with it
i need to really get like a bunch of
presidential facts
like
like a list of stuff that lines up with
with rappers i love founding father's
best oh yeah oh yeah i'm into those
mount rushmore uh
maybe some with a declaration of
independence that's like death row
records they all come together and sign
it that's pretty good
something like that it could be like the
declaration of independence is the first
diss track hey
diss track yes
all right all right
you know the republican and democrat
it's almost like east coast west coast
yeah something there you know blood's in
the crips the red and the blue wait a
minute
uh the wig party
i don't want to say it out loud but
you change the w yeah all right no no
yeah it's going to say the white people
rap like that
like eminem
would be called a
part of the wig party i see what you're
saying wigger
there you go all right all right you're
not supposed to say that word name i
don't think so really yeah i don't think
it's bigger
i know but those are
that's a different word i know but it's
uh
all right what are you supposed to say
um
whack
that kind of works
that kind of works all right
yeah there's something about that for
sure the the uh
hmm
joe zimmerman had that great bit about
uh i think it's hamilton no it was
andrew jackson jackson yeah that's a
great bit yeah and i'm not a history
buff and i don't know anything about
andrew jackson but his bid is so good
because it it like plays it all out it
gives you all the information it still
makes it funny
has ever been underrated joe zimmerman
new album out check out joe zimmerman uh
tours with brian regan yep yeah he's a
terrific comic killer comic
funny guy look him up joe zimmerman he's
done a bunch of late night sets as well
that are strong but mark i think the
joke mark's talking about is in a uh
craig ferguson set over here on late
night maybe during conan maybe on the
patreon play it and we can play more
stuff yeah sure that's his like
signature bit yeah no he's he's great um
we'll save it all right but uh oh yeah i
got one that's hitting but it needs one
more thing all right
i'm missing is hits but i say
you know you can't really tell if you're
in a toxic relationship you can tell
afterwards
you're looking back you'd be like that
was bad you can't tell when you're in it
you know what i mean which like that's
the only thing that's like that my phone
breaks
i know it's broken instantly i'm not
walking around with a cracked screen
your friends are like what's up with
your phone i'm like you should see it
when you're not around
it's actually
it's actually a pretty good phone right
so maybe you should mind your own
[ __ ] business yeah worry about your
phone looks like an android to me looks
like you know that i don't i don't have
like a that part gets a nice pop but i
need like a they i don't have an ending
like the android thing i'm like thinking
like something like your phone looks
like something maybe about fingers you
know
the identity thing or the security thing
i was thinking uh it also could i know
you got the phone part already but my
brain goes to alcohol you know like hey
oh [ __ ] like hey this uh this is a good
drink and i'm feeling good what's the
reminder there for i don't know how to
fix it it just goes off i pushed a bunch
of buttons one day and now it goes off
at 2 2 pm every day
but i just turn it off but
you have a drink it feels good it tastes
good but then later you're like oh what
was in that you know you're so hungover
like later you're like oh that was toxic
that was poison but at the time you're
like this is fun
i know so many alcohol jokes yeah
there's something about like the phone
though there's something like um
you know you're sharing letting other
people look at your phone that's like a
vulnerable thing
oh yeah letting someone in to see your
partner that's a vulnerable thing right
right
um your phone if your phone's not
working that that it's like like a
relationship that's like chaos yeah
true true well you're just like man your
phone is so it's just the phone
the comp is the phone is like like the
girlfriend the toxic girlfriend well
it's not like it because if your phone
breaks
right you know it is if you're if you're
if your relation breaks you're kind of
the last to know oh that's good that's
kind of my point
maybe the only difference is
if you lose the girlfriend you feel
better you lose your phone
you're ruined yeah if someone else finds
your girlfriend oh yeah yeah yeah there
you go or something like yeah you've uh
and there's a store you can go to like
my phone's not working i guess that
would be uh couples
yeah you go to uh yeah we're not
connecting you know something like that
either way yeah with the phone though
the phone's uh acting up you get a new
model yeah
yeah there you go
yeah
huh
i'll crack it i like them here i like it
yeah i'll play with it
so much phone girlfriend stuff too it's
just like you gotta text all the time
you gotta post about her
yeah um
maybe someone with a case
on a phone
you gotta protect it yeah it's broken
like the screen is broken gotta protect
it
yeah
someone else asked if they could touch
it they're like absolutely not yeah
finger your own girlfriend
keep your fingers on your own
keep your fingers away from what's mine
right yeah you're out of memory
uh yeah you got to have memory gotta
have a real friend yeah you better have
memory
all right how often do you get accused
of not remembering oh my god you didn't
remember like i know i can't remember
everything yeah then i then i uh can
tell you what wade bogg's batting
average was and
there's never one three six or three
yeah oh really isn't that maybe not
maybe i just who knows but you're like
hey you don't remember that i like when
you work the balls
all right
all right mark where are you gonna be on
the road man hey
i'm all over the place uh
let's see atlanta buckhead theater
milwaukee improv charlotte comedy zone
royal oak
in mark ridley's comedy castle in
michigan kansas city improv syracuse
funny bone ah
my nemesis
but a lot of fun dates coming up go to
normancomedy.com as well at the uh dark
oh i'm mark
comedy fest i gotta go i gotta do
toronto man uh i got uh charlotte comedy
zone coming up december 2nd through 4th
i got miami improv the following weekend
then the addison improv in dallas uh we
got uh richmond uh coming up richmond
virginia in january we got timonia
maryland sacramento i'm adding i'm gonna
add some other [ __ ] in january to pull
some stuff just for my own sanity yeah
i'm gonna try to take a vacation first
one ever we'll see how that works i
don't [ __ ] know how to do it you're
going uh going on a trip not far but i
can't go too far all right you know next
[ __ ] but i will uh
you're going with your phone
yeah i'm bringing both phones
[Music]
[Music]
you